now here's a question for you kid you
tell the difference between a priceless
piece of art and a fake well that's the
challenge in a new series on Sky Arts
it's called fake the great masterpiece
challenges presented by the art
historian Rose bull sterner before we
speak to Rose let's take a look at what
a program is all about public are being
challenged to look more closely than
ever before but the nation's art
I'm going to go full budget Sherlock
Holmes I think it could be that one and
it's that one that's what we want
families to break up both of it
[Music]
well I wouldn't have a clue and since
the rate of phases is this is the idea
of the show isn't it to challenge people
to try and spot fake and to teach you
how to yeah absolutely
and the great thing about the program is
that people were encouraged to go into
the galleries to look closely at the
paintings to really look at paintings
and ways in which they hadn't done
before in order to be able to kind of
create a kind of emotional connection
with the paintings and really look
closely how on earth can ordinary
members of the public like us if we
raise an art gallery we wouldn't have a
clue how can normal people possibly know
when something's fake emanating
well it's all about looking closely of
course and there's various things that
you can look out for so one of the most
important things that I felt was that
you should look at the color so if
you're looking at painting that's 300
years old
of course the paint is going to get a
little bit dark it's going to look old
it's going to look aged and so if you
suddenly got a painting that's really
fresh really bright colors but doesn't
look aged at all then that's a bit of a
giveaway another side to it is whether
there's any cracking on the surface of
the paint and cracking is a so sure sign
of age there is two important things to
look out for it's like looking for a
needle in a haystack with I think of
just London where we live all the
galleries all those paintings millions
and millions and paintings you just said
people go and find a fake oh no it's
hard okay yet that was happily wrote and
I would be and even some of the
professionals as well Connie you have to
remember that yeah but it wasn't like
that so so there were eight different
galleries with eight episodes and in the
first seven episodes we had one room in
each gallery which had ten designated
paintings that were could potentially be
one of the copies and then so we had we
only had ten paintings throughout group
and then the public would look for the
copy within that term yet looking in the
whole of London we'll move it that's
pretty easy okay I mean idea is the
people who are looking for these fakes
they learn a little bit about the artist
because obviously if you know van Gogh
for example if you know him inside out
you'll know what to look out for and
what his signatures are
you know yeah the hallmarks of his are
it so yes if you already know a little
bit about art then yes you can look for
those signatures so if you're looking
for say again gain for painting you know
we've got quite light and feathery
brushstrokes but actually it wasn't just
for people who knew about art it was for
anyone and this was a great thing about
the show was that families came in with
young children people who never been
into art galleries before and it was
just a very good mechanism they're sort
of detective element of it to get people
into the galleries to look closely at
art and you'll see when you watch this
series I mean so many people said I've
never looked at art in this way before
I've never felt that art could be
engaging and interesting but because of
this sort of slightly for the detective
element of it people loved it and they
weren't really thrilled and excited that
they spent this amount of time with a
look at their cool art detective yeah
it's good like that yeah and I love the
fact that you presented it with Giles
Coren because him behind you now I like
his food critic column in the paper he's
so rude as he is reading ha ha ha ha
jazz is a very kind erudite witty man
and I I thought he was delightful I
wasn't entirely sure what to expect but
yeah he was delightful to work with and
the great thing about him is that you
know he put before her series he didn't
know a huge amount about art so he was
looking at the paintings with quite
fresh eyes so it's thrilling for me to
see how he responded to the work as it
was with all the general public as royal
master did it fool energy experts did
someone come out of this looking a bit
foolish because they didn't spot the
real thing or the fake one and the
matter
there was never there was never to aim
to make anyone look foolish at all I
mean if some people who are very
knowledgeable about art didn't get it
right then that is a testament to how
brilliant your peers were and indeed
they really were incredibly talented
artists from their own right and you've
traveled all over the country filming
this it's not just in London you've been
to Liverpool Manchester and Cardiff as
well exploring the art covers yes indeed
and and Edinburgh as well and that's the
point you know so often we think that
the great art in Britain is in London
but actually the regional collections
are fantastic and all of the galleries
that we dealt with are free
to the public to enter so it's our arts
that we can see every day if we want to
you know we can go into any of these
galleries for free and that was the
point that we highlight regional art as
well and the great brilliance of
regional arts okay Rose really
interesting to speak to you rose Boston
faked the great masterpiece challenges
on Sky Arts now thank you very much
thanks Stella come here on Sunrise we're
going to take a look at the sports
headlines any of those fake Jackie all
right no good no space for no fakes
bought marina though running out of
patience I think